Abba reached out to us to help promote
their new Reno 10 Pro Plus 5G because
apparently this thing has a killer
camera so today we are going to be
comparing it to Samsung's Galaxy s23
plus and comparing a bunch of different
things including the cameras designs
displays and more so let's cut to the
Chase and jump straight into the cameras
as you can see this camera bump on the
Oppo is a beast look at it it definitely
looks like it's packing some power in
there compared to these three little
bumps on the Galaxy and here you can
even see the little Periscope camera
within it right there I'm super excited
to test that out now comparing the
actual camera specs the s23 plus comes
with a 50 megapixel main camera a 12
megapixel Ultra wide and a 10 megapixel
telephoto but on the Reno 10 Pro Plus we
have a 50 megapixel main 8 megapixel
Ultra ride and a 64 megapixel Periscope
telephoto camera which sounds absolutely
insane but what makes it even better is
that the Reno 10 Pro Plus actually has a
periscope telephoto camera with a sensor
that is 388 larger than the telephoto
sensor in the s23 plus and then moving
over to the front the s23 plus has a 12
megapixel selfie sensor which is pretty
standard but the Reno has a 32 megapixel
selfie camera which should be a lot more
detailed and now comparing the actual
camera quality you can see that both of
the 50 megapixel main cameras look very
similar they both look great they're
both very very good and then as far as
the ultra wide cameras even though the
Apple has an 8 megapixel it still holds
up very well compared to the one in the
s23 plus but then moving on to the 3x
telephoto this is where the difference
really starts to shine as you can see in
these photos the portraits just look a
lot better on the Oppo because of that
huge sensor it takes in more light which
leads to less noise and an overall
better image especially with oppos AI
HDR which also works very well the
awesome thing about the Reno 10 Pro Plus
is that when you zoom in with that 64
megapixel sensor like let's say 6X Zoom
it actually crops in on the sensor to
give you almost lossless quality which
looks really really good compared to the
s23 plus which honestly starts to fall
apart when you go past 3x so the Oppo
looks quite a bit better especially when
you start zooming in to 10x and even
further and this thing can even zoom up
to
120 x which is amazing compared to the
s23 plus which only goes up to 30. and
one of the most important things with
that huge 64 megapixel sensor is that
you also get a lot better low-light
quality compared to the smaller 10
megapixel telephoto you get a lot less
noise overall you just get so much more
clarity with the image with the Reno 10
Pro Plus and then moving on to selfies
that 32 megapixel sensor is giving you a
lot more quality as you can see here
there's just so much more detail
compared to the s23 plus and now moving
on to comparing the designs and build
quality you might think that the Oppo is
a lot heavier because of all of that
Tech jam packed into it especially with
the cameras but they're actually both
around 194 grams so they both feel great
in your hands but one thing I'm noticing
as I'm holding them right now is that
the Reno 10 Pro Plus actually feels
really nice soft and comfortable in your
hand because the edges are rounded and
so is the back of the phone so it feels
very comfy whereas it kind of feels more
squared off with the s23 plus with that
flat back so it kind of feels a little
bit bulky kind of like it digs into your
palm a little bit so I really like the
design of this Oppo now as far as colors
the s23 plus has a flat black paint
finish as you can see right here but the
Oppo has this really nice kind of
gradient shiny bluish tint that changes
depending on how the light is hitting it
it looks really cool and as far as the
actual button layouts they're both
identical both right here on the right
side only with the volume rocker and
power button right below almost looks
like they're practically the same but I
really like it it's in the perfect spot
and now let's get into comparing the
displays the s23 plus has a 6.6 inch
flat display panel with about 393 pixels
per inch but then on the Reno 10 Pro
Plus 5G we have a 6.7 inch display
that's actually curved around the edges
so it makes it look like the bezels are
thinner and it actually has 450 PPI
which is about 15 percent higher
resolution than the s23 and then in
terms of the actual Peak brightness in
knits the Reno 10 Pro Plus 5G has a 1400
nit display while the s23 is actually a
little bit brighter
1750 but they're both very bright so
they're fairly easy to see outside in
the sun but on top of that the Oppo has
a really cool feature called Pro xdr
where it's able to adjust the brightness
and shoot it up on the display using the
actual HDR to show brightness like it
should be for example if I turn this off
that lamp behind me is very dull but
keeping it on it brightens it up using
the HDR display and now testing the
actual display quality with an HDR video
in YouTube you guys can see that that
extra knits on the Samsung s23 is
helping out because you can see the
colors are popping more on the s23 plus
right here you're getting extra
brightness while the apple looks to have
more natural colors that are a little
bit subdued and not pushed really high
like on the s23 where the saturation
just looks really pushed like you got
blues oranges just pushed to the extreme
where this looks a little bit more
natural and balanced and on top of that
the Oppo does have a more sharp display
with more resolution so it looks a
little bit more crisp compared to the
Samsung and now the last thing I want to
compare is the UI differences between
the two as you can see here we have a
traditional button UI right here where
you have the app switcher the button and
you kind of can swipe around it's the
standard Samsung UI well on the Apple I
really like how it's similar to how the
iPhone is set up you have kind of like
your news and other stuff right here you
could swipe between your different pages
and then when you swipe up and stop you
actually have your app switcher where
you can close apps just with a full lick
of a finger I really like this UI a lot
better and another big difference is the
charging speed the s23 plus supports 45
watt fast charging while the Oppo
supports 100 watt supervox charging with
the charger that comes in the box which
by the way the Samsung does not come
with a charger in the box and then this
thing can hit 50 in just 10 minutes of
charging or 100 in less than 30 minutes
which is absolutely insane so much
faster charging than the s23 plus so
with all that said and tested if I
honestly gotta say that the Oppo Reno 10
Pro Plus 5G is a better purchase
especially with that 64 megapixel
Periscope telephoto lens this is just a
really good phone so hopefully you enjoy
this video let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]